este misil sin explotar es una de las
múltiples razones para que muchos de los
habitantes de esta localidad a las
afueras de mykolaiv hayan decidido
marcharse
en este edificio una bomba racimo causó
daños en decenas de apartamentos
incluido el de marina que nació en la
unión soviética de padre ruso y madre
ucraniana
yo nací aquí yo vivo aquí como es esto
posible toda mi familia mi familia está
en rusia y todos ahí nos dicen que
estamos mintiendo y que putin es una
buena persona
la historia familiar de este grupo de
vecinas es similar desde la invasión
rusa prefieren pasar la mayor parte del
tiempo en el refugio antiaéreo donde
hace menos frío que en sus viviendas
averiadas todas están solas sus familias
han decidido marcharse de la ciudad y
ellas se cuidan mutuamente vivimos en
permanente tensión vamos a la farmacia y
no hay nada no hay esto ni lo otro no
somos jóvenes todos tenemos la tensión
alta
estos edificios fueron atacados a
finales de febrero entonces las fuerzas
rusas ucranianas se enfrentaban por el
control de esta pequeña localidad
conocida como cool back y no que al
igual que mykolaiv esta estratégica en
la defensa del puerto de odessa a 135
kilómetros al oeste esta parte es
importante porque hay un aeropuerto muy
cerca y una fábrica especializada en
reparar aviones actualmente los rusos
han sido obligados a retroceder 50
kilómetros pero los ataques aéreos ahora
llegan con mayor insistencia al centro
de nikolai como podría estar preparado
para algo así
este hotel recuerda la historia reciente
en mykolaiv durante la unión soviética
la ciudad estaba cerrada al mundo
exterior aquí funcionaban los astilleros
más importantes y los pocos funcionarios
autorizados para visitarla se hospedaban
en este lugar
este edificio fue construida en tiempos
de la unión soviética
aproximadamente hace 40 años más
adelante cuando compramos el hotel lo
remodelamos y lo he tenido por 15 años
en esta pequeña casa todos han decidido
quedarse solo hay mujeres con niños y
personas mayores que no dejaron la
ciudad tenemos muy pocos hombres conocen
los riesgos de caer en las manos del
ejército ruso que argumenta que su
presencia en ucrania es para salvar de
la opresión habitantes rusoparlantes con
estrechos vínculos con rusia como la
mayoría mykolaiv